horas cruciales para la democracia en
Guatemala minutos antes de que el
tribunal electoral oficializara los
resultados de las elecciones donde
Sandra Torres y Bernardo Arévalo se
disputarán la presidencia del país en
segunda vuelta un juez suspendió el
movimiento semilla de Arévalo acusándolo
de financiamiento electoral ilícito a
solicitud de la fiscalía especial contra
la impunidad el juzgado séptimo
distancia penal ordenó la suspensión de
la personalidad jurídica del partido
político movimiento semilla pero no es
la primera controversia que rodea la
contienda una resolución de la corte
constitucional de Guatemala ordenó
revisar los resultados de la primera
vuelta por pedido de nueve partidos
afines al oficialismo generando
incertidumbre Aunque para muchos
guatemaltecos se trata de una lucha
contra el statu quo mismo juez que ahora
intenta
entrometerse en el proceso electoral
este juez es el que metió a la cárcel al
periodista José Rubén Zamora por digamos
en un sin ningún fundamento Así mismo ha
perseguido a varios Fiscales que están
en este momento en el exilio o presos es
decir el el Ministerio Público es un
actor al Servicio del presidente para
entrometerse en prácticamente todos los
procesos y perseguir a sí mismo a los
opositores políticos
antes tres candidatos a la presidencia
con serias posibilidades de pasar a la
segunda vuelta fueron excluidos los tres
tenían en común un discurso antisistema
la organización de Naciones Unidas la
Unión Europea y Estados Unidos mostraron
su preocupación por estas intervenciones
en la elección un riesgo que persiste
pese al fallo del tribunal electoral por
ahora los guatemaltecos cuentan las
horas para el 20 de agosto donde se
juega el futuro y la democracia del país
centroamericano